the other classic on that of course is
uh 20th century to say domestic violence
i was about to like give you the back
yeah while we're on [ __ ] let's just keep
talking about domestic girlfriend if
we're talking about love okay he's not
going to stop talking
we we've seen it on your channel yeah we
can go we've seen your videos we can
literally go and get the fountain of
like non-existent youth from you on this
this thing where you just never age and
you talk about this for ten years i can
i can continually talk about it i don't
wanna give me a five minute you got you
get five minutes gone sell sell this to
me because i watched i watched three
episodes and i immediately dropped a
domestic girlfriend [ __ ] awoke
something in me man
like
you this this this
single show basically dictated my hentai
taste from like so there's me before
domestic girlfriend and there's me after
domestic
so wait if i'm correct is it there
there's a guy and there's a teacher yeah
and there's a sector okay okay so that's
correct okay so let me let me break it
down for you okay so there's this guy
who has who's in love with his teacher
right and
one day he just randomly goes up to a
meet-up and uh he meets another girl at
a karaoke uh what's what's it called in
a car like uh
bar
what's what's what's what's the event
where
i make sure thank you sydney you know
she goes to a mixer and he meets this
girl and this girl for some reason wants
to lose her virginity because she just
at the age where she's just like [ __ ] it
i got nothing better to do doesn't the
anime literally open with them like yeah
after the anime literally opens up with
them just off okay right and so he
sleeps with this girl and then he's who
he's just met and then they say goodbye
um and then he goes home and then he
finds out that his dad's getting
remarried and then he meets the family
that he's getting like his dad's getting
married to and it turns out that the
mother of or his future mother-in-law
uh or his future stepmother
uh she has two daughters one is the girl
he slept with and the other is the
teacher he's in love with
and that is the premise of this
girlfriend
literally this is this is incessant and
this is just like this is like what if
we made all pawn categories into one
this is what it sounds like basically
this is like basically combine every
point where are the laundry machines
okay four of them in this action
okay so like i will fully admit that the
the concept i mean yeah this is this is
a hentai block okay this is this is your
this is this is your kisses
it's better than it is people
like when we did the anime three by
three people were like why why is the
domestic girlfriend anime not on there
it's because i actually read the manga i
think it's a good [ __ ] manga and i
will defend it till the day i [ __ ]
die would you say it's a masterpiece i
would say i mean
it's a masterpiece in my heart okay
no because like i understand because
like what happens is like this
masterpiece is short for masturbating
yes but like okay what what i love about
this manga is that it takes the most
like it's the situation is a complete
car wreck and it just turns to a car
wreck to a train wreck to a [ __ ]
nuclear holocaust like the
like the layers of how
complicated the situation get just just
get stacked on top of each other but
what what offsets this is that it's
actually a really well written manga
it's like
a a lot of you're being very oxymoronic
right now okay okay okay because a lot
of thought was really put into the
characters so the characters actually
seem really realistic and you can kind
of like empathize with them right
what's what you can't relate to is the
[ __ ] situation that they're in so you
put really
you put like you put actual like
realistic characters or well-written
characters into this really [ __ ]
trashy wacky situation and it's such
it's like a juxtaposition of just you're
actually invested in these characters
but also the stuff that's happening is
so wild that you just want to keep
reading just to see what happens next
it's like a soap opera but the
characters are actually really like
you're you're really really invested in
these characters
i i just couldn't get to that point with
the anime honestly
what's more of a battle this or kingdom
what's more of an epic battle
it's two different battles isn't it
which is the bigger battleground oh oh
oh
i don't know which one's more five head
man one of them is like you're
physically getting hurt because the
other is like chipping away your brain
yeah okay because because like the the
anime is a really okay what the anime
did is that it just took all the trashy
moments in the manga without any of the
character moments and just put them and
just speed ran it so it made a bit of a
bad pawner huh they made it bad yeah but
he made a bad porno okay
it's uh i mean what what porno doesn't
have character development well
well how can i engage most of them a
good one
we don't need it
and uh yeah i i will i will keep talking
about dimensions sure if you want to
hear talk about it just ask him in
public ask him anywhere
watch the 17 videos he made on it i
realized i realized that uh i've made
like a manga three by three uh hentai
three by three i'd say a dojin three by
three this is all in and uh an anime
three by three and all of them have
incest in it i just i just
[Applause]
got three brothers oh i've got a sister
and i've been [ __ ] look all i'm saying
is at least i don't like stepmom porn
because
everyone has a mother what like
everybody everyone everyone has a mother
what's your excuse what's your excuse
connor for mother's no mother knows
breasts